The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: In
some ways, today's class,
it's the most challenging
of the semester.
These are really complicated,
difficult threshold issues.
And we're just starting to
see the powerful ramifications
of having gotten a number of
things wrong in this space
and what it does.
So I try to put
the manufacturing
stuff in early so you'd see
that there are real issues here,
not just kind of abstract
science policy questions,
but real issues that
have big implications.
So let me start with Samuelson.
And you're all probably
familiar with him,
but probably among a handful
of the most famous economists
of the 20th century--
one of MIT'S great
stars, an amazing figure,
lived well into his 90s.
I heard him talk just a few
years ago, before he died.
And he was incredibly sharp
and funny and astute--
just a phenomenal figure.
And he really rethought--
really was a
foundational creator
of neoclassical
economics-- the attempt
to bring discipline metrics
to economic thinking.
So then he writes
this surprising piece
in 2004, which takes on
mainstream economics.
Now, he had actually done
writing on this topic,
coming to somewhat
similar conclusions
much, much earlier
in his career.
But he comes back
to it in this piece.
And it took everybody
aback, right.
Mainstream economics
had thought this was
a completely settled territory.
Mainstream economists
like Greenspan,
Jagdish Bhagwati, Gregory
Mankiw, they were arguing--
and this is a
quote from Mankiw--
"Yes, good jobs may be
lost in the short run,
but still total US net
national product must,
by economic laws of
comparative advantage,
be raised in the long run--
and in China, too.
Never forget the real gains of
consumers alongside admitted
possible losses of some
producers in this working out
of what Schumpeter called
'creative capitalist
destruction.'
Correct economic law recognizes
that some American groups can
be hurt by dynamic free trade.
But correct economic
law vindicates the word
'creative' destruction
by its proof
that the gains of
the American winners
are big enough to more than
compensate for the losers."
And then Samuelson concludes,
"The last paragraph can only
be in innuendo, for
it is dead wrong
about the necessary supply
of winnings over losings."
So here is the guy who created
mainstream economics taking
on the whole economic mainstream
assumption about the benefits
and gains of trade.
And it's a startling moment.
This article was like
a bombshell in 2004.
So how could the US be a loser
in competition with a low wage,
lower cost competitor
like China-- obviously,
there's others--
despite David Ricardo's theory
of comparative advantage?
And remember, we talked
in the first class
about Ricardo's theory
of comparative advantage.
We had the example of
Portugal and England.
England gets a lot of rain,
and it has a lot of grass.
It grows sheep.
Portugal has a lot more
sun and a lot less rain.
It grows grapes.
It produces wine and port.
Each side trades to their
comparative advantage.
Now, he's thinking of a
resource advantage, right.
He's not thinking about
a comparative innovation
advantage.
So what happens in the time
from Ricardo to the present,
is that nations begin building
a comparative innovation
advantage through building
strong innovation systems,
right.
And arguably, the US leads
that effort, coming out
of World War II to develop
a comparative innovation
advantage.
And Samuelson goes on
to argue that if China
or another comparable
country begins
to make productivity-enhancing
gains in its production
and couples that with
a wage advantage,
it can capture some of the
comparative advantage that
had belonged to a
competitor like the US.
So in a Ricardo sense,
there's never unemployment
that lasts forever from trade.
It will eventually
sort itself out, right.
But the way in which it's
been sorting itself out
is that, as he
puts it, real wages
have been lowered by this
version of dynamic fair trade.
So to compete, wages come
down, right, in the US.
And that's what's been going on.
So wages can drop
after a time to a point
where a productivity enhancement
or productivity advantage
in another country is offset.
But these are still net
harmful terms of trade.
And this is not a
new story, right.
This story has been going on for
a long time, Samuelson argues.
So farming moves from the
eastern part of the United
States to the Midwest.
That's a straight
comparative advantage--
the ability to scale up
agricultural production
in the Midwest, as opposed
to the more crowded East
and hillier East
and rockier East.
We can see it.
We understand why
agricultural production
shifts to the Midwest.
Textile and shoe manufacturing
moved from New England
to the lower wage South
early at the beginning
of the 20th century.
English manufacturing
leadership shifts to the US,
starting in the middle of
the 19th century, right.
We develop the early
stages of mass production
through interchangeable,
machine-made parts, not
Britain.
And we'll talk more about
that in a later class.
So as Samuelson
puts it, even where
the leaders continue to
progress in absolute growth,
their rate of growth
tended to be attenuated
by an adverse headwind
generated from lower wage
competitors and other
technical imitators
in each one of these examples.
Right, so this is an
old economic story
that he's raising.
So a productivity
gain in one country
can benefit that country alone,
while permanently hurting
the other country by
reducing the gains
from trade that are possible
between the two countries.
And all of this,
he acknowledges,
is long-run
Schumpeterian effects--
creative destruction
of capitalism effects.
And he concludes that in effect
is a roulette wheel of evolving
comparative advantage.
Now his warning
is a powerful one.
If you respond with
tariffs and protectionism,
you will be breeding
economic arterial sclerosis.
You will be limiting
your ability
to effectively and
efficiently compete.
So that's not a fix in his mind.
So this is one of the
most important economists
of the last century,
and a good part of this,
weighing in on an
historic conclusion
that economics came to about
the overall benefits of trade,
and saying it's a much more
complicated story than that.
So it was a powerful message
when he put this out.
So I just finished
talking about Samuelson.
So we're all set up for you to
do us your view of Samuelson
and lead us into some Q&A.
AUDIENCE: He sounded very
certain of all of this, right.
And this was something that a
lot of people actually asked
about as well, is if he's
so sure if this is something
that's regarded to be
pretty substantial,
why did it take the mainstream
and why did it take economists
at large a lot of years to
start changing their mentality?
And I remember
last week, we were
talking about the US's
hesitation as a country
to change their economic
outlook in certain ways.
So I was wondering if anyone
thought that those two were
related somehow.
So it's kind of two
separate questions.
Why did it take
forever for people
to start adopting his views?
And does it have something
to do with cultural factors
in the United States
or any other factors?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
I have a comment.
It's Lilly.
I was thinking
about the timeline.
So Samuelson starts to put
forward earlier than the 1970s
or even in the '60s?
Because he got the Nobel Prize
in '72, and in his speech
he talks about it.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
And this is not the
main work for which
he's been recognized for.
But with an economist
named Wolfgang Stolfer,
the two of them
put out a doctrine
on advantages and disadvantages
of trading regimes
pretty early in their career.
And I'm thinking
the '50s, but I'd
have to go back and
check the actual dates.
AUDIENCE: OK.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So he kind of launches
that theoretical, highly
mathematical framework.
He returns to it in 2004
because, in his view,
the mainstream of economics,
which, of course, he created,
has taken a departing path
by assuming the continuing
eternal benefits of
free trading system
without really analyzing the
competitive processes that
are going on here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And just
add one more thing, Lilly,
there's an economist at
MIT named David Autor who
is doing startling work--
and I refer to them in
some of the other readings
we got into-- but doing
startling work on these very
significant trade impacts.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I listened
to some of his interviews.
But I'm kind of wondering what
precipitated Samuelson to write
this sort of explosive article.
I'm trying to think back.
And I think Alan Greenspan--
wasn't he the economic advisor
during the Clinton era?
So he would have been--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: No,
he was in the Bush--
AUDIENCE: He was?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: --II regime.
AUDIENCE: OK.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
OK, so then NAFTA
pre-dated Greenspan.
But yeah, I'm just
wondering about the timing
of this article and what really
prompted Samuelson to finally
be like, listen, everyone,
this is completely wrong.
Yeah, maybe people
weren't paying attention
until post-NAFTA or
other trade agreements,
and then it started to become
really more noticeable?
[AUDIENCE: I mean,
we'd discussed
before that the US doesn't
really respond until things
start going south, right.
So.
[CHUCKLES]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah, our
motto could be "be unprepared."
AUDIENCE: Or I would
have loved for Mankiw
to say that quote, like,
OK, yeah, tell that
to the losers. (LAUGHING)
Like, it's totally fine.
Don't worry.
The winners are going to win
higher than the losers are
going to lose, so it's OK.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
And it's not that there haven't
been a significant net gains,
right.
Consumers are, no
question about it,
significant beneficiaries
of the regime.
But there just are
dramatic effects,
is what Samuelson is arguing.
AUDIENCE: And I think it sort of
assumed in creative destruction
that like, the winners win
bigger than the losers are
going to lose.
And then you center
the winners--
I don't know.
Maybe in the US we've
just been the winners
for like a lot of these
consecutive creative
destruction periods or cycles.
And then we have to deal with
sort of competing productivity
rates, I guess, [INAUDIBLE].
And then now it's
probably a little bit more
of an issue in China.
And so the losing
end starts expanding
towards Samuelson's
sphere of influence, which
is probably inside the US.
And he writes this in,
what, in like 2004?
And so China is really
becoming sort of the forefront
of what we're considering.
And I guess, I think Greenspan--
I just looked him up-- he's
like chairman of the Fed
at this time, from '87 to 2006.
So he sees all of this,
but he's just probably
not in a position to respond.
And he can't really kind of
shift everybody's opinion
here, because there's
a lot of, I guess,
sort of like gravity in the way
that mainstream economics is
thinking that he's just got
to follow that, I would say.
And then, while
Samuelson doesn't really
have these restrictions
or rules [INAUDIBLE]..
He's got the backing
of having created
and the legitimacy of having
created mainstream economics.
So I think it's pretty OK
to disagree with yourself.
But it's probably
a little bit harder
to disagree with the
massive wave of folks, which
is why it might have taken
these other folks a little bit
more time to respond,
AUDIENCE: He always wanted to
break the status quo, it seems,
with economics.
Well, regarding the
winners-and-losers discussion,
I think people also mentioned
that that sort of thought
process might
drive a wedge, too,
that could create
income inequality.
And the question was, does this
model of international trade--
does free trade inherently
create that income inequality?
Or are there other things
that contribute to that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But what I would add
to that is, so maybe we
do make more money
than we lose, right.
But the distribution
will be affected, because
most likely it will be--
I think I made this point last
week with one of the Intel
founders, where it was like, you
end up making way more money,
but you're not going
to spread the wealth,
because those jobs that amass
the middle wealth aren't here.
So I think, yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah,
that was your quote, Martin,
from Andy Grove of Intel.
It was a great quote.
AUDIENCE: And so I think
that's a big problem.
Especially with like, Apple,
most of the manufacturing work
is outside the US.
And the other problem, too, that
we haven't gotten to is taxes.
A lot of times companies use
tax loopholes effectively.
So maybe that money
should be coming here.
And I think I made
this point when
I was making my
notes on this piece,
is there's a lot of
hidden variables.
And the author constrained
his variables in such a way
to make a certain point.
And there's a lot
of variables that he
didn't take into account for
how people actually do things.
So theoretically,
it might work out.
But in terms of the actual,
how it gets done in practice,
I don't think it does.
AUDIENCE: Does Autor
take into account, maybe
in his mathematical laws a
couple of these tax loopholes
and how people are actually
sort of using these systems,
rather than kind of ignoring
them as variables to kind
of make their point here?
Because I wonder if Autor
is analyzing the way
that people actually
and effectively
use these trade laws in this
kind of globalized system.
Like, will he arrive
at the same result?
Or will we end up getting
that income inequality?
AUDIENCE: But like, one of
the papers that he wrote
looks at specific communities or
areas that were heavily focused
on an industry that's now gone.
So it's looking at real people
and how their real incomes have
changed.
So I think it was like
furniture in North Carolina
or something like that.
And so you can prove just by
looking at that group of people
before and after that there
has been income changes
and that the support
that they're receiving
from the government hasn't made
up for those changes in income
that they're getting.
So if you use that
as an example,
that can show that those
income inequalities remain.
AUDIENCE: OK, well, I think
a lot of the economists who
are mainstream economists who
are providing globalization,
when they talk about
net gains being made,
they talk about [INAUDIBLE]
they almost necessitate
this assumption that
they all get spread out.
But we don't necessarily
see that for sure.
I do feel like
[INAUDIBLE] like it
was a little bit of
a contrived example.
But I think that is to the
point that what he was doing
was specifically showing
that current ideas
about globalization always
being good isn't always true.
And he only really
needed to provide
a single example there
to explain why China
and India were [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Just to add, I
think that another point was
that a lot of this debate
is kind of predicated
on the idea of trickle down.
And I think going back to
the question of why now,
or why are we [doing this now,
is that you've kind of been
successively proving that
trickle down has some
limitations-- has a
lot of limitations--
especially considering
developments in other countries
and how the market clearing
wage rate of the United States
has just been subject
to a natural reduction
due to increased capital and
innovation in other countries.
And so the gap between
the winners and the losers
kind of has a widened and has
made that trickle-down process
even less [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So why don't we
dive into the next
reading, which
was Gary Pisano and Willy Shih.
And that's yours,
too, Kevin, right?
OK, great.
I'll just summarize
very quickly.
And you can add more.
But this is an
article they wrote.
They later turned this into
quite a well-known book.
And in this article--
and they later expand on it--
they look at a whole
set of technology areas.
But they start from the
Kindle 2 and point out
that very large portions
of that technology
can no longer be produced
in the United States.
This is the source for a
number of the components,
that it can only be made in
various countries abroad.
So they argue that
there's an eroding US
ability to create virtually
every brand of notebook
computer, except Apple.
And mobile handheld designs are
now largely in Asia, as well.
So then they look at a whole
series of technology fields,
right, and find
that there's been
a lot of erosion
in US leadership
in a series of these areas, from
advanced materials to computing
and communications.
They identify fields
that are gone.
And they identify fields that
remain competitive and at risk.
Same story for energy
technologies and storage,
for different aspects of
semiconductor industry
and for the display sector.
So the erosion of these
industrial capabilities,
they essentially portray.
So they help us take
the Samuelson theory
and make it much more
concrete in terms
of actual affected
industry segments that
are no longer present at
significant scale in the US.
So let me leave
it to you, Kevin.
It's all yours.
AUDIENCE: Well,
that's true, yeah.
The, I think, big
focus in the paper
was the destructive behavior
that outsourcing has caused.
And you're right.
Like you said, it's causing
the ability for the US
to create now.
And I think following
our previous talks
on how governments
should intervene
in these kinds of situations
to sort of fix the issue,
what role should government
play in intervening
in company decisions that affect
their profits when innovation
for the US is the consequence--
the US being able to
influence the consequence
to any [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Well, one answer is,
[INAUDIBLE] I was wondering,
does this outsourcing,
other than unemployment,
does this really harm
the US to that extent?
Because they argue that there's
a reduced industrial commons?
And what if this
transfer of industrial
commons in other countries--
does it really affect
the US that much?
Why can't the US still benefit
from industrial commons
from overseas other
than loss of employment?
Do you see what I mean?
AUDIENCE: And I think that's
an especially relevant point
in this innovation wave where a
global economy is more relevant
than it was in the past.
I don't know the answer
to that question.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: If I had to guess,
I'd say that, well, we
can benefit from it.
But the benefits
that we would get
would be orders
of magnitude less
than the benefits of
the country that hosts
this industrial commons, right?
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: So it would mean
having employment benefits.
They'd get extra tax revenue.
Just, their economy
in general-- like
they might be able to even
undergo an entire innovation
wave because of this.
So yeah.
It's not so much that
we can't benefit,
so much that it is that
other people are benefiting
more, which means that
they can get ahead
in other technologies.
So if you look at
long-term, then that
puts them ahead in a
lot of other fields.
And that's just not good
for the US interest.
AUDIENCE: So but to
that point, yeah,
it might help in the short-term,
but then the long-term
what happens is they
build up capabilities
that we've just never had.
Like in business, we talk a
lot about compound interest.
So a lot of the value will
be created in the future.
So the problem is more like
10 years in the future,
they can produce things that we
never build up the capability.
And those are
things that it's not
like knowing-- it's like
actually creating your supply
chain in a certain way
and creating the system.
Silicon Valley
took like 80 years
to become Silicon
Valley because you
need a lot of [INAUDIBLE],,
a lot of mentors,
a lot of different expertises.
And so my big worry
when I'm reading this
is more that we are very
short-term-focused in the US.
We don't really save.
We always assume the future's
going to be optimistic.
And this is a point from
Peter Thiel, Professor,
since I know you
kind of like him.
And like Asian countries
tend to be more--
let's say I think, like 30% to
[INAUDIBLE] a long-term focus.
So I think that's really a
key point with this piece,
that we're very
short-term-focused.
We're trying to find the
big win very quickly.
So that's why our industries
are kind of like tech--
technologies that
don't matter as much--
Wall Street, finance,
which debateably
doesn't add that much value.
And these other industries
take a long time.
But you'll get a
lot of capabilities
that you won't be able to get.
AUDIENCE: What was
the paper where--
it was Japan that
looked hundreds of years
into the future and have that
anecdote about an advisor
or someone.
And he said, oh, yeah, this is
my plan for the next 100 years.
And he was criticized for
thinking too short-term.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: [CHUCKLES]
Right.
AUDIENCE: I think it's
interesting also--
I understand very strongly the
point you're making about how
other countries would
then benefit when we move
our [INAUDIBLE] overseas--
but what's the link
between maybe moving
those processes overseas and
making room for new ideas
to be borne?
And if maybe the
US takes on more
of an innovative and
purely like the idea--
like blackboard
kind of innovation--
and then ships the idea
to another country where
they can actually produce them?
Does there need to be
that separation for us
to be able to have
the room to innovate?
Or can we still innovate and
keep all of our stuff here?
AUDIENCE: I think
we can innovate.
I don't know that the
US would like moving
most of their profits overseas.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Let me
jump in with a couple of slides
that I was going to use later.
But they're relevant-- very
relevant to this discussion.
So this is the share of
employment in services
versus manufacturing.
So that's the left-hand chart.
So services in the US,
86%, production, 14%.
It's actually somewhat
lower than that.
And then that's the share
of earnings in the Standard
& Poor 500 coming from
manufacturing versus services,
right.
So one reason why
you manufacture
is, that's where
the money is, right.
It's not in services.
So if you develop an economy
that's overwhelmingly services,
as we have been heading
for for a long time,
look at the returns, right.
And then-- I'm really
jumping ahead here--
but let's look at
the trade balance
for high technology goods versus
all manufactured products.
So the US is running a
gigantic trade deficit
in all manufactured products.
But now, we're
running a major trade
deficit in advanced
manufacturing technologies.
So that goes right to
your point, Chloe, right?
Let's cede commodity production
and make it up on the high end.
Except we're not
doing that, right.
Instead, the whole
picture looks bleak.
[LAUGHTER]
Right.
This class is designed
to scare you to death.
AUDIENCE: Yup.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I find that isn't it
counter-intuitive for
the US to train so much
international students, and
knowing that most of them
will return to
their home country
and contribute to the
industry commons over there?
AUDIENCE: Well, see,
that's fascinating,
because I heard the
assumption actually
be that the US keeps the
international students,
and that's why.
I mean, we've mentioned it
in several classes, right?
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE], right?
AUDIENCE: They might still do.
AUDIENCE: Probably true,
but maybe at a lesser rate.
Because I think the
opportunities available now
in the US manufacturing sector,
just like outside the US--
for people that come
here and do train,
it's now a lot more
feasible for me to go back,
whereas previously I
would have had to stay.
And so we're seeing sort of
a decreasing rate [INAUDIBLE]
to stay.
AUDIENCE: More desirable
to stay, right?
It's like the common
example we've used in class,
I think maybe two
or three times,
is that with every diploma
and cap received in the US,
we should staple a visa.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Heck,
let's staple a green card.
To heck with the visa.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: A green card, sorry.
That's what I mean.
But yeah, so what
does the data actually
look like on that bill?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well,
a significant portion
of students from abroad
do stay here, right.
But the numbers are in decline.
And more are going back
to their home countries.
But does that mean--
you all tell me--
that the US ought
to close its doors
to international students?
Right, is that
what we should do?
Right, is that the
right economic strategy?
We've got somebody who
thinks it is, at the moment.
AUDIENCE: You know yesterday
he passed another one, right?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, I know.
[LAUGHTER]
No.
No, really-- I'm asking
in a serious kind of way.
I mean, the US
model, historically,
was to have these
international universities
and attract talent from
all over the place.
Because if you're running
an innovation system
that feeds talent for
the entire world, what
an incredible competitive
advantage, right?
What an incredible
competitive opportunity.
But I think the other
side of that coin
is that it's a value in itself.
And yeah, you really asked
some terrific questions
in your email to me.
And this is one of them.
What are these Americans doing?
Right.
What do they think
they're doing here?
But I still think
it's of overall value
to have as much talent here,
because that's how knowledge
gets sharpened, right.
That's how we get
sharper and better.
And so that would
be my argument.
But people should
feel free to disagree.
AUDIENCE: So in a way that--
I feel really uncomfortable
when people say,
I want to play the
devil's advocate.
Because I feel like those people
are trying to be incendiary.
But I certainly have had
peers in the past that
would have raised the
point of this conversation
about whether students who are
coming from other countries
might be considered
spies, because they
would be then understanding
knowledge and the innovation
or sort of innovation
paradigm, and then
taking it back to
their home countries.
And that also makes
me feel uncomfortable,
because I feel like trust
sort of precludes cooperation.
And it precludes the
United States' ability
to work in a globalized system.
So I was hoping that you
could talk about that a little
as well.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: In the
end, having a world talent base
with common education
experiences--
that's very powerful for
the world in general.
I mean, that's a
real huge net plus.
And we can't assume
that all innovation is
going to happen in
the United States
and we can wall ourselves off.
It's important for innovation
to occur elsewhere.
There's an old story about
small towns and lawyers, right.
So if there's a small town
and there's one lawyer,
the lawyer is going to starve.
If there's a small
town and two lawyers,
they're both going
to get rich, right.
Because their clients will be
suing each other constantly,
right.
In other words, they're going
to create more net, right.
And if China is doing
brilliant things
to bring 300, 400 or
more million people
into its middle class, that's
a great thing for the world.
That's a great, overall
incredible net plus,
to create a massive
new middle class.
And if the US can't figure out
how to take advantage of that,
then shame on us, right.
Because it's really important
that the world do these things,
right.
Same story in India.
Same story and all kinds of
other developing countries
that are starting to
become emerging economies.
So these things need to happen.
And we're not going to
be able to wall them off.
We just have to figure out--
to develop our own
competitive capabilities
to be participating.
That would be what
I would argue.
Now, a lot of people
see this differently.
Matthew?
AUDIENCE: I think
another benefit--
even if you didn't care about
the Chinese middle class
or India's middle class, and
if you just cared about the US,
you'd still have to
recognize that we don't have
the comparative
advantage in everything
such as advanced manufacturing.
By having those
international students there,
like say, a Sloan
student who was working
in manufacturing in China--
just as much as they're
maybe benefiting
from the US education and
that innovation mindset,
they're sharing with their
peers their experiences.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think that's important.
And when we consider
the educational model
and bringing international
people into that,
I think it's important to
not adopt the perspective
that we're the only ones
who have anything to offer.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: You got it.
AUDIENCE: Other people
bring other perspectives.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: And that's valuable
even just for our benefit,
not to mention other countries'
benefit, which is good.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So, Luyao
have we answered your question?
Yeah?
Are you satisfied with what
we've talked about here?
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLES]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
You can critique us.
AUDIENCE: Well,
personally I think
it, just for the
sake of the world,
is benefiting to have an
international base of talents.
And there are
countries that see this
as a national strategic
move, to attract talents,
like Singapore.
But because they are such a
small country and their only
resources-- the human talents--
then I don't know if the
US sees this as something
of national importance.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
Your Singapore example
is very astute.
It's really interesting.
Because Singapore, at least
until fairly recently,
had a strategy for
higher education,
in particular
graduate education,
to get its students out
into the world, right--
to send them to the best
educational institutions
around the world, so that they
would learn other countries
and how they worked
and what ideas
could be gained from them--
and that they would be able
to set up relationships
with those countries.
They would be able to
have working relationships
with the communities
that they learned.
And Singapore--
small island nation--
city-state, really--
no real resources.
They have to trade to live.
So they organize themselves
around becoming intermediaries
in all kinds of
trading activities
worldwide, whether
it's petroleum
and oil and fossil
fuels, or it's
running the world's
most efficient port
or running the most efficient
cargo transport aircraft
operation in the
world, they figured out
these intermediary spots.
And then they used their
relationship building
to be able to build the
relationships they needed
to play that dramatic
intermediary role benefited
by their geography.
So it's a very interesting
example, Luyao,
of a country that's adopted kind
of a broad look at education
and where to get it.
AUDIENCE: And to
add on to that--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Please.
AUDIENCE: --with that kind of
strategy, there are, of course,
social costs.
There are like local hatreds
of international laborers.
And the government
takes a responsibility
to settle this conflict
instead of reducing
international
talents, because they
see this as a strategic move.
And so it is the question,
like, when we see maybe
there is an outsourcing
of manufacturing,
there are loss of talents.
Or do we just stop doing it?
Or should the government
take the responsibility
to solve the social
costs associated
with this kind of move,
together with globalization?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Have at it, team.
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: So on the
point of education,
higher education, that's one of
the US's important abilities.
So it's a really good thing.
It's dangerous to
assume that that's
going to be a core strength
for a long period of time.
So people will learn
from us and [INAUDIBLE]
There's a couple good
universities popping up
in other countries
that are doing well.
I think the big danger, though,
is the point [INAUDIBLE]
made previously about why should
[INAUDIBLE] create more value?
Because ideas don't matter as
much as the execution of ideas.
Like, there's a
ton of people who
came up with social networks.
Facebook had 15 social
networks beforehand.
But it wasn't until one
person executed it right.
So the danger is, we could
invent something here,
and another company in
China has-- he's like,
oh, that's a great idea.
We can do that.
We can do it better.
And we can do it cheaper.
And that's the real kind of
thing I would worry about,
is that capability of
being able to execute.
And it's something
that's hard to understand
until you've see it just
happen and gone through it.
But that's the danger.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So
Kevin, how about another
question-- a closing question
on Gary Pisano and Willy Shih.
AUDIENCE: Throughout
this whole discussion--
this might be beyond
the scope of the class--
there's a question that
popped into my head.
If there stands to be
so much mutual benefit
from global cooperation, why
don't countries prioritize it?
That might be an
idealistic view.
But if economies now are
so interconnected by trade
and competition and everything,
why don't governments
of the world cooperate to
sort of prop each other up?
And I'm as cynical as
the next person, right.
I understand human greed and
the desire for money, right--
desire to be the best.
But why can't everyone
sort of be the best?
AUDIENCE: That's
a good question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLES]
AUDIENCE: So often
the people who
have to make these
decisions, they usually
want to put their people first--
like, hey, America first.
So that usually means
it's America first
at the cost of anyone else.
So if you have 196
governments, all of which who
are thinking like that,
then, well, you kind of
end up where we are today.
And it's short-term, yes.
And I'll try to play a
bit of devil's advocate.
I know you hate that, Lilly.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I hate it.
AUDIENCE: I love it.
Honestly, I love that phrase.
AUDIENCE: As an
intellectual exercise,
I think it's important.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But if you do it
from not a place of trying
to find an understanding
with other people,
then I think it
is irresponsible.
AUDIENCE: So I see the--
I lost my point.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Global
corporate [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Yeah, so I see why long-term
it would be good to cooperate.
But in the short-term,
if somebody, say,
reneges on a deal
when you've already
put billions and billions
of dollars into it,
that could hurt
you significantly.
And then they could
get away scot-free.
And then they
could realize, hey,
I've damaged this country that--
I don't know-- for
whatever reason,
I wanted to have less economic
benefit than what I'm getting.
So basically, it comes
down to mistrust.
So like that could happen.
Yes, "we are the world."
I'd love for it to happen.
But I think it's going
to take a long time.
AUDIENCE: So to point
out, we've definitely
done the whole reneging
thing a billion times.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Colonialism exists.
So--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: --we've
definitely gone
to countries and different
places around the world,
and really just
ravished for resources,
technological abilities,
what have you.
And then, I think there's
a longstanding history
of us kind of doing that and not
doing it right, just because it
is so advantageous for one
party to renege or do it wrong
and go in for the wrong
reasons in the first place.
And I think that
level of trust is
sort of hard to build
from that history,
but also, in the
case of [INAUDIBLE]
so let's say you build this
multi-national cooperation
and somebody does sort
of renege on a deal,
I can't see really
a conflict mediation
peace or a medium there that
doesn't escalate very quickly,
especially when large economic
threats are involved-- so maybe
war or something.
War is the extreme
example, but like tariffs--
there could be large trade
implications that now--
whereas previously they would
have been isolated to larger
countries, but now that
it's multi-national,
it affects sort of everybody.
AUDIENCE: I'm trying to think of
a memoir I was reading recently
about a woman named
Wangari Maathai in Kenya
about her experiences of growing
up right as British colonialism
was taking off in the 1940s.
And she was speaking of
the ways in which society
had been structured
in her village
and that different ethnic
groups had become, I guess,
specialized in
certain capacities.
Like, some people were very
good at basket weaving.
Other people had become
very good at agriculture.
Other people have become
very good at medicine.
And each of those communities
taught themselves those trades
and perpetuated that
sort of, I guess,
capacity within generations.
And then British
colonialism came in.
They started exploiting people
for agricultural production.
And that entire system imploded,
and along with it, [INAUDIBLE]
culture, the knowledge
that they had,
the agricultural
systems that had
taken them thousands of years
to formulate, et cetera.
And I think it's precisely what
this woman is talking about--
why cooperation is so difficult,
which is why I brought up game
theory I think two classes ago--
because cooperation and
collaboration are so important,
but they rest so much a
sort of fundamental trust.
And that kind of
collaboration always
sort of implies
a power imbalance
that is negated by
that sense of trust.
And it's so difficult
on a global scale
to enact trust and
collaboration because there
is such a sense of
histories and colonialism
of power imbalances-- of
domination and hegemony.
And because we have
been, for the past 200
years in the United States,
such strong actors in that,
we've never had to take this
into consideration before.
And I think now, in particular--
I really wish that
we had more students
in this course who
were sort of coming
from defense backgrounds.
Because I feel like
we don't talk enough
about the implications of war or
the implications bioterrorism.
But I do think it's
certainly important to think
about collaboration
as our ideal.
But as we were talking
about last week
in the social organization
of organizations,
how is it that we can sort of
have a layered approach, where
there is collaboration
existing in a system
where we feel that
we are respecting
power dynamics, and
also the potential
for us to be heard in the
short and the long run.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because when
I think of collaboration
between nations, the first
example that comes to me
is like World War I--
Axis versus Allies.
They were in great
collaboration teams.
And then that embroiled
us into a massive mess
because fights
between one and each
let to fights
between all of them.
So I think you raise the
issue of that occurring.
AUDIENCE: Well, actually
to counter that--
the difference between now
and World War I is currently,
as we saw in the last week's
readings are our economies
are just so linked, we
can't have that again.
Because then, the entire world
could just completely collapse.
And honestly, you
probably can't even
have the war, because you
need the gunpowder produced,
I don't know, in one country.
You'd need the bullet
casing produced
in another country, the
stock for a rifle built
in a third country.
Everything is so interconnected,
as was pointed out,
that, well, we can't
even mobilize very well.
AUDIENCE: But what
if [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: If you're just
using rifles and sticks.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I don't care.
OK, yeah.
Everyone gets sticks.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I'm
going to put us back
into manufacturing
and out of war.
AUDIENCE: I mean, look at
the opposing view, though.
There's a lot of
value in conflict.
Like, in management,
we do this a lot,
where it's like you
will put out something
to make it seem like you're
doing bad when you're actually
doing OK so that people
will get to work.
I think a good example was,
like in Silicon Valley,
somebody made out a
white paper about like,
oh, this is the
distribution of diversity.
And a lot of the times,
it's very illogical.
But it's actually the
person you don't expect,
because they want people
to focus on that topic.
So I think there's
a lot of value
from creating that conflict.
So I think on the macro, I think
we are in a relative peace.
Because is there
ever going to be
a time with no conflict at all?
Right, it's too utopian.
So what you do is,
it's macro-utopian.
But you create these minor
issues that really don't matter
[INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Maybe.
Kevin, why don't you give us a
closing thought on this piece.
AUDIENCE: Well, to counter all
the points, it's hard to tell--
especially in the
long, long term--
which is more sustainable--
our historical behaviors
or whatever future
model we come up with.
But maybe the next big
innovation wave for the US
is a global one and not just
one leaning to the country.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Interesting.
All right.
We'll now dive into Jonas Nahm
and Ed Steinfeld, both of whom
worked in MIT.
So Jonas is now teaching
at Johns Hopkins SAIS.
And he's from Germany, fluent
Mandarin, spent lots and lots
of time in China.
So he knows both German
and Chinese economics
and manufacturing
systems, in particular.
Ed Steinfeld has gone on to head
the Watson Institute at Brown
from MIT political
science department.
Both are terrific
scholars of the kind
of manufacturing
advances that China
has been able to put together.
So this dramatic thing happens.
China moves from 5.7% of global
manufacturing output in 2000
to almost 20% in 2011,
passing the US in output.
I mean, that is
startling, right.
Those numbers jump off the page.
How did that happen?
Right.
So what happened here?
So the operating
assumption in the US
has been that China
had lower production
costs due to lower wage
costs and lower cost parts.
That was the
operating assumption.
And then there's been
an assumption in the US
that manufacturing naturally
migrates to low-cost producers
and that the knowledge required
for manufacturing processes
is comparatively trivial.
And Nahm and Steinfeld argue,
neither of those is true.
The assumption that
production knowledge
flowed via multinationals
from outside into China--
it's a much more
complicated story than that.
The assumption that the IT
revolution enables severing
of manufacturing from R&D--
from production and design--
and turns out to be a
more complicated story.
And none of these explanations
explain that dramatic rise
in China's production
capability and output.
Instead, they argue
that China has developed
some remarkable new process
innovation and manufacturing
innovation.
And that needs to be
understood and respected
as a major innovation advance.
So China has tended, they argue,
to specialize in rapid scale-up
and cost reduction,
in combination.
And they join really
remarkable skills
in simultaneous management
of the tempo of production
and production volume
and controlling cost,
and that that's a very powerful
set of skills and capabilities,
and that these kinds of factors
are much better explanations
for that remarkable rise than
simply a wage differential.
So they argue that this has
enabled China to expand even
in industries that are
highly automated or not
on governmental priority lists.
And low costs and
government support
are just not
sufficient to explain
China's remarkable
accomplishments
in manufacturing.
So let's get more into
a little detail here.
China's developing
production processes
in areas that were
previously thought
fully mature and impervious
to additional cost reductions
or technological improvement.
China's taken on various sectors
and shown that, in fact, you
can bring innovation to
these in process and in cost.
So the key has been accumulation
of firm-specific expertise
that has enabled what they call
"extensive, multidirectional,
inter-firm learning."
In other words, they're able
to get a community of producers
to operate together in a
unified kind of way that's
kind of unthinkable in
the much more fragmented,
decentralized US system--
to build a level of
cooperation, particularly
in a regional basis, that is
able to scale up production
very quickly in ways that
are pretty unprecedented.
So elements of China's
new production model,
they argue, include
backward design capability--
in other words, taking
an existing product
and rethinking it,
right, so that you
can create lower cost production
systems for those components,
and therefore be able to sell
it into a lower cost, lower
wage Chinese economy, right,
in a creative kind of way here.
Yes, there's been a
partnership of foreign design
and Chinese manufacturing.
But that has been
multidirectional, they argue.
Both sides have been
informing each other.
And technology absorption
and collaborative development
across networked production
firms has been remarkable.
That's part of this ability
to do rapid scale-up.
So these are all new
elements that we haven't
seen in production systems, that
China's been able, they argue,
to put together in unique ways.
So an explanation of Chinese
manufacturing as just a wage
advantage completely
understates, they argue,
what, in fact, China
has accomplished here.
It's a remarkable story.
So we have to kind
of keep this in mind
as we confront these global
competitive issues in the class
today.
It's not a simple story
of a wage advantage.
It's a much more complex
and interesting and
innovation-based story.
AUDIENCE: When we're putting
into detail about why China
was so successful,
why it could do things
in such a short time span, but
my question and the question
some people have as
well was, what next,
in terms of trade
relationships between--
economic relationships
between the US--
the United States, especially
in this political climate?
Are they a force to
be reckoned with?
Are we going to learn from them?
AUDIENCE: So actually
part of my thinking
that maybe they had
such a rapid growth
because, if you think about
it, they have a lot of people,
I think a lot of resources.
AUDIENCE: Untapped potential.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, they just
haven't tapped their potential
until relatively recently.
The fact that they were
able to do it so quickly
is pretty remarkable.
But beyond that, the fact that
they are where they are now
should not be that surprising.
Yeah, I feel like they have
the expertise to do it.
And the internet's made
information pretty easy to get.
So I don't know, maybe like
all manufacturing [INAUDIBLE]
you can't easily get, but.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I do think,
kind of in line with this paper,
there's this presumption that if
we weren't buying manufactured
goods from China, we could
just make them in the US.
But that's pretty clearly not
true, especially as emphasized
by a lot of these reading.
Like, we simply can't
make them any more.
So I see that there
can be a lot of talk
about not purchasing as
many goods from China.
But if we want to
maintain our lifestyles,
have Kindles, have
these other devices,
I don't see a realistic way
in the short-term for us
to not have some
dependence on China.
Like, long-term we
could change our systems
and try to gain back
some of that footing.
But I think a lot of it
is just talk right now.
AUDIENCE: And digging into why
China has the advantage here,
I think it's two things--
mostly because work
and kind of their life
has been very integrated.
For example, at factories,
like semiconductor factories,
you live in dorms.
And you go to work.
And there's not
that much separation
between your work
and your actual life.
So there's very
much an expectation
that you are very devoted
and dedicated to your work.
And also, I think
in China it's less
stigmatized to go into like
kind of manufacturing and work
on these really
innovation-driven
from manufacturing, kind
of in a reverse process.
And so that means a
lot of the academics
there aren't afraid to go
into these fields, which
is important because, especially
in a field like semiconductors,
you need a lot of
technical expertise
even though it might
just be manufacturing.
If you want to make
those improvements--
make them faster,
smaller, et cetera--
you have to be able to have that
background to innovate further.
And I think that's why
a lot of these firms
have been having success, taking
that extra step beyond just
learning from the innovations
posed by other countries.
And this might be a
little bit controversial,
but I think the government
structure in China
also has had a big
role in why they're
able to make that
happen so quickly,
because they're able
to come up with an idea
and turn it around really
quickly because it's
very integrated and
more unilateral, as
opposed to our structure here.
So if they have a
construction project,
like they want to make a bridge
happen, it'll happen in a year.
In the US, it would probably
take like three years.
AUDIENCE: At least.
AUDIENCE: Or yeah, if that.
And it might not even happen.
AUDIENCE: Well, that's true.
The directed focus
of a government
definitely has some advantages.
Like, if you want something
done, it gets done.
But on the other hand,
there are disadvantages too.
Like, any disagreement,
and it might end up
being a bridge that points
upward for no reason.
So then it's not
actually useful,
even if, oh, yeah, we got it
done really quickly and really
under-budget, it
doesn't actually
solve the problem
as well as it could,
whatever the problem might be.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Kevin, why don't we
lead you back into this.
How are you reacting
to these comments?
AUDIENCE: So not only with the
discussion with this paper,
but with other papers
we've been discussing
short versus long-term in
terms of what direction
the nation might head in,
in terms of innovation.
Speaking of short-term
now, what do people
feel the US's reaction would be?
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Can we fast-forward maybe
like one slide, two slides?
Yeah, one more please.
Mm-hmm.
[LAUGHTER]
There we go.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: It's OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I think there is an
opportunity here in this second
point with this partnership
of foreign [INAUDIBLE]----
rather than kind of
walling ourselves off
in the short-term, if we can
kind of just accept that they
have this--
I don't even want to say
like a built-in advantage--
but they've actually constructed
a system that we've just
learned is super effective.
And so rather than
kind of copying
the Chinese model, which
will take structurally
a lot more time and might even
be impossible because we're
so fragmented, or kind
of walling ourselves off,
I think it just might be
important to just capture
on this partnership
of foreign design
and Chinese manufacturing,
and facilitate
that multidirectional learning.
So hopefully some of the
trends will come back.
But at the end of
the day, I think
if I sprout a mustache
and glasses and a tie,
will I say this is OK?
[LAUGHTER]
But you're going to
have to just look
towards what's the
next innovation wave
so that we can kind of
capitalize on those.
And I hope that those that
don't all go to China.
Because I think
we've kind of already
lost the ball on
what they've done
with backward design and
these network production
firms because of structure
and how they do things.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: We'll
come back to that, Rasheed,
when we talk about these
advanced manufacturing
partnerships.
AUDIENCE: I agree only
in small part with you
on that, because I think
we need to be really
careful in the short-term.
Because we do maintain
the capability of--
so for example, in this paper,
[INAUDIBLE] solar cells.
We can do that in
the United States.
Problem is, in China,
the Chinese government
is dumping subsidies.
So yeah, that's marginally
legal or even illegal.
But how long is it going
to take us to work that out
in an international court?
So we need very much
forge ahead with--
or protect what we
can still do here.
I agree with you, we
need to understand
that there are some things that
China does better-- maybe even
adopt some of their practices.
But we need to protect what
we can still do, I think.
Because we don't want to
lose the entire solar market.
And then they take
their subsidies away,
and we could have competed.
You know what I mean?
AUDIENCE: Two questions-- or
two things I wanted to bring up.
One, I didn't realize--
is it illegal to subsidize
your own industry?
AUDIENCE: In a lot
of trade agreements
there are rules about
what you can do.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: There
are anti-dumping rules.
In other words, can you
dump on a foreign market
a good that's produced and
sold at less than its cost
to produce.
Right.
So that's where you
begin to run into issues.
AUDIENCE: Because
then internationally,
they're ruining the ability
of other countries to produce.
And then when they take
those subsidies away,
they're no longer
cheaper or better.
AUDIENCE: They're
just the only options.
AUDIENCE: They're just
the only [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
But remember, too,
Lilly, that China
is selling its solar capability
into its own market because
of its own staggering
demand for power resources.
So this is not
entirely an attempt
to capture world solar markets.
This is serving a pretty
strong need in its own power
development areas.
AUDIENCE: Just a
[INAUDIBLE] point--
from the Chinese market
preference perspective,
there's this
mysterious preference
for foreign goods,
especially US-made products
over our made-in-China goods.
So I do see the US still
has this advantage.
For example, if there's two
medicines for you to choose--
there is one made in China, and
there is one three times more
expensive but it's
made in the US--
people who can afford
it, will just buy it,
like without any reason.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
That's fascinating.
AUDIENCE: Is it?
AUDIENCE: My counterpoint
is, it's that way for now.
But there's a thing called the
"innovator's dilemma," which is
a common strategy in business.
What you do, is you make the
product that isn't that great,
but it's cheaper.
And then what happens is
you do that specifically
so your competitors
don't attack you.
It's the equivalent of, say
you're at a dinner table
and there's a person
who eats a lot.
Right, he eats like 10 plates.
And there's somebody who eats
like one little appetizer.
You don't mind that
eating the appetizer.
So they focus on
industries or markets
that the big player
can't attack.
And they slowly grow
their advantage.
There's a strategy that was
used by Japanese companies
with cars.
They made the cheap car
that companies in the US
wouldn't focus on until
they could make cars
that were much, much better.
But it's a common strategy.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: OK.
So a closing thought,
Kevin, on this great debate
you've kicked off here?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Well,
these next four years
are going to be interesting.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
It's going to be
very interesting.
AUDIENCE: Oh, sorry.
I didn't [INAUDIBLE]
my second thought.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Feel free.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that happens.
So I was thinking
back to the point
that Chris had pointed
out, that there
are differences
between our government
and the Chinese government.
I think one of the
differences that comes in--
I'm not certain about
China's government.
I don't know-- are
there term limits?
Are there limits built into
these governmental permissions
that, say, force them to be
re-elected every so often?
AUDIENCE: I think probably,
but it's longer, right.
AUDIENCE: It is
every four years.
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's also four?
AUDIENCE: Really?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
their policies [INAUDIBLE]??
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I don't
know much about it at all.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, me neither.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: It's not
really elected.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: OK, OK.
AUDIENCE: It's like [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So it's
a dictatorship.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: OK.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All right.
AUDIENCE: Then that--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: --yeah-- my point
to that would be that, well,
then the governmental officials
can think a lot more long-term.
Because the way that our current
electoral system is made,
at least representatives
have to think
like two years in advance.
And that's basically the
most they can think of.
They need to produce results
within that very short time
period.
Senators, they have six years.
A president, if he's
lucky, he gets eight.
So there's just a
different emphasis
on what the governments
are able to do
and what they're
incentivized to do.
So with that, if we
were to try to adopt
that kind of a
structure, we'd have
to make some radical
changes to the Constitution
and a lot of stuff.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
It's hard for democracies
to think longer term.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All right.
So we're going to dive
into Suzanne Berger's work
on the "Production in the
Innovation Economy" study.
So we talked last
class about her work
on distributed production.
And she led this big study
at MIT, the "PIE" study--
"Production in the
Innovation Economy."
Pulled together a whole faculty
group from a variety of fields
and ended up with this
in-depth, two-volume study
of what had been happening
in US production.
And I think there's some
very important stories here.
I had you read the kind
of preliminary report.
The depth in the two volumes
is really quite powerful.
So if you want to read
further in this area,
this is a great place to start.
So Suzanne wrote the kind
of cover, overall view,
drawing on chapters that
particular faculty members
and researchers pulled
together in different segments.
And then she did that
kind of overview piece.
The overview piece is one
of the most powerful books,
in my view, that's been
written about US manufacturing.
So well worth thinking about.
You're just getting a
kind of early snapshot,
frankly, from the preliminary
report I had you read.
But I want to try and
pull out, frankly,
blending the preliminary
report with my knowledge
of the underlying
report some stories
that I think help us
understand what's been going on
in US manufacturing.
And she tells a series
of these in her book.
One story is that
manufacturing turns out
not to be agriculture.
And I'll explain
what in heaven's name
I'm talking about in a minute.
Secondly, that our manufacturing
firms are increasingly,
as she puts it, "home alone,"
that small, mid-sized,
and startup firms are
having a lot of trouble
scaling up their
production in the US.
A fourth story is about if you
want to keep strong innovation,
you need to think about
the link between innovation
and production, which this
book argues is profound--
that there's a real link between
innovation and production.
There's deep workforce
training education issues.
There's important
lessons from Germany.
And then there's some very
interesting jobs stories here,
too.
So let me try and
tell these quickly.
First, manufacturing
is not agriculture.
For a long time, the economists
thought that manufacturing
was agriculture.
In other words, in 1900,
half the population--
not quite-- but half the
population was farming.
And now less than 2% of
the population is farming.
And we're producing
much, much more, right.
So it's a story of
staggering productivity gains
and advances.
But the MIT report takes
that argument apart.
So economists were
saying, oh, this
is just productivity gains.
We're just much more
efficient in production.
So what if you lost one
third of your manufacturing
jobs between 2000 and 2010?
No problem.
Productivity gains, right.
But then the story turns out
to be much more complicated.
We thought that manufacturing
output was holding firm.
But it turns out that
it wasn't, right.
So we thought we were producing
the same with less labor.
But it wasn't the case.
In fact, in 15 of 19 industrial
sectors, we had output decline.
And our official statistics
overestimated output
because we adopted a view of
computing and IT technologies
that assumed the components,
for definitional reasons,
were because the United States.
But they weren't, right.
That's the Willy Shih,
Gary Pisano story, right.
So we were completely
inflating our numbers.
And output wasn't what
we thought it was.
So if output, which is obviously
half the story of productivity,
is not what you thought it was,
then the productivity numbers
were considerably lower
than mainstream economics
had been telling us.
It's not that there
weren't productivity gains
in that period.
There were.
But they weren't what
we thought they were.
So instead, the job loss
numbers really tells us
the sector is hollowing out,
not getting more productive.
So a second story--
what Suzanne calls the
"home alone" story.
So she tells a story that,
for the last several decades,
we've been thinning out in the
US our manufacturing sector.
We used to have firms
and supply chains that
had to be very
vertically integrated.
This is the story we told last
week about LEGOs and model
airplanes, right.
We hit on a financial model.
And Martin, you had been
pointing some of this out.
We hit on a financial model that
emphasized quarterly returns,
which led us to want to reduce
interim risk, which led us
in the financial sector
to focus on getting firms
to nurture their
core competency,
not do a lot of other stuff.
So therefore, they should go
what's called "asset light."
Strip the firm of
assets that are not
part of its core competency.
Right.
So we began to thin out what
had been these very vertically
integrated groups of firms.
So the companies in the system
are now much more "home alone."
Story number 3 is related.
This is the scale-up problem.
So the US is home to
a large percentage
of the world's multinationals.
They're global.
They can get
production efficiencies
by producing in
lower-cost countries.
And they need to be
in global markets.
They don't have an option here.
They need to be worldwide.
Generally speaking, they're OK.
They're producing more abroad
than they did in the past.
But there's two much
more vulnerable sectors.
So one of those sectors
are what we could call,
and what the book calls,
"Main Street firms."
So these are the small
and mid-sized firms.
So there are between 250,000
and 300,000-- let's call
the 250,000 of these
small and mid-sized firms
that employ less
than 500 people.
That is most of the
manufacturing sector, that's
a majority of US production.
They have trouble
getting scale-up funding.
They are thinly capitalized.
They have to be risk
averse to survive.
They don't do what we would
consider R&D, although they
can be very innovative in
modifying products and changing
processes.
But they don't do
what we would consider
innovation-based research.
So they're kind of outside
of the US innovation system.
And there are a lot of them.
It's a big part of this.
For them to innovate,
they have to have
access to ideas, which they
don't necessarily have,
and a thinned-out ecosystem.
And they've got to have
the financing to scale up.
Part of the Production in
the Innovation Economy study
was led by John Reed, who
was head of the MIT Executive
Committee and former
chairman of Citicorp--
a brilliant, famous
banker, who created
a lot of the amazing
Citicorp model.
John Reed was part of
these deliberations.
And he said, yes, we ended local
banking in the United States.
That was the historic era where
your neighborhood banker would
know, in your city or town,
who the quality producers were
and know who to lend to.
That's gone.
We substituted really
national and then
international financing models.
And we replaced that
face-to-face, kind
of relationship-based banking
to a very significant extent.
The Main Street firms
were dramatically
affected by their ability
to get scale-up money out
of their banking system.
Right, it really hit them.
And there isn't really
a substitute for them.
And then meanwhile-- and we'll
talk about this more later
in class--
the other
manufacturing community
is entrepreneurial
startups that want
to make something-- that want
to make a hard technology.
Unfortunately, the
venture capital system
has walked from this territory.
So venture capital at this point
in the US funds predominantly
software, secondarily
biotech, then
a series of service sectors like
media entertainment business
services.
They're not funding firms
that want to make something,
that have hard technologies.
So the implications of this
are really quite powerful.
That's part of the reason why
Rafael Reif put The Engine
together down the
street, because a lot
of MIT-developed hard technology
was just not getting out.
We had to have a different
way to stand them up.
But this is where the next
generation of manufacturing
will come from.
This is what the next
generation of manufactured goods
will come from.
And we're not doing it.
Right.
Big-time societal
implications here.
So there's a big scale-up
problem for these two, right.
How are you going to scale
up innovative production
and innovative technologies?
We're in trouble to the
extent we rely on them.
We rely on them a lot.
This is just a chart that
shows who does the R&D.
So large companies do R&D.
Small companies don't.
Right.
So the small
companies are just not
part of the innovation system.
Story 4-- the relationship
between innovation
and production.
So what's wrong with
scaling up abroad?
The issue is that for most
products-- not all products--
and it looks like there's a lot
of exceptions in the IT area--
but for most products,
you need your innovation
pretty closely
related, particularly
to your initial
production stage.
In other words, there's
a lot of interchange
as you design for production.
You take your idea, and you
design it for production.
Right.
That's a very creative process.
Lots of engineering.
You often have to rethink
your basic science.
So if you're shifting your
production capability abroad--
and this is the most important
conclusion of the PIE study--
you're starting to affect
your innovation capability.
So the US has thought that its
competitive advantage, really
since the end of World War
II, is in a strong innovation
system.
But if it's shifting
production--
particularly
initial production--
it's losing that interaction
between initial production
and its innovation capability.
So a fifth story
is, how do you begin
to wrestle with these issues?
They looked hard at workforce.
So there's lots of
workforce studies out.
And they consist
of CEOs saying, we
don't have enough
skilled workers.
And the MIT approach, led
by Paul Osterman, a faculty
member at Sloan, said, look,
let's not ask the CEOs, right.
The CEOs may be saying
there's a tremendous shortage
of $10,000 Cadillacs, right.
That may be what they're,
in effect, saying.
In other words, what
they're prepared to pay
for skills is not an appropriate
compensation for the skills.
It doesn't match markets.
So let's actually ask the
human resources departments.
And let's not ask them, are
you short of skilled workers?
Let's ask them, how
long did it take
you to hire for positions that
have come up in your firm?
And what they found was that
75% of the firms studied--
and they reached
way over 1,000--
I think was several thousand--
they were able to
hire within one month.
Now, that's logical.
Because, after all, we just laid
off almost 6 million production
workers, right.
And they've been largely shunted
into the lower end service
sectors.
Maybe they would
want to come back.
So presumably, there's a
surplus of capability out there.
But the most interesting
part of what they found
was that for 25% of
the firms, they weren't
able to hire in a month.
It was taking them a lot longer.
And interestingly, these
tended to be the smaller,
more innovative,
technology-focused firms.
And they were having a
much harder time, actually,
because they needed a higher
skill raft of workers.
They are having a lot of trouble
hiring in a reasonable time
frame.
So Paul Osterman would
summarize saying,
there's not an
immediate emergency here
on workforce skills.
But we're going to
have trouble ahead.
And the signal is the 25%
of more innovative firms
that are having more trouble
getting the skill sets
that they needed.
And look, we've got a
big demographics problem.
So the manufacturing workforce
is an aging workforce.
And it's going to
need replacing.
Sixth story-- and there's only
one more to go after this--
what can we learn from Germany?
So the US has been sitting
around for at least a decade--
more like 20 years--
thinking, oh, we have to
lose manufacturing jobs,
because we're high
wage and high cost.
So we have to lose these jobs.
Somebody never sent
that memo to Germany.
They failed to get
that word, right.
Because Germany is much
higher wage and higher
cost than the United States.
Their wages and benefits are 66%
higher for their manufacturing
workers than for US
manufacturing workers.
And they are running staggering
trade surpluses with everybody,
including a major trade
surplus with Germany--
I mean with China, excuse me.
What are they doing?
They're supposed to
lose this sector,
right, according
to our thinking.
But they didn't.
So the US has about 8% of its
workforce in production jobs.
Germany, 20%.
What are they doing?
Right.
This is an important
set of lessons here.
How has Germany organized
its manufacturing sector
so that it's able to run
an extremely successful
manufacturing sector
that continues
to bring major returns
back to its economy,
even though it's very
high wage and high cost?
What are they doing?
Right.
So there may be important
lessons for us to learn.
And the PIE study, in fact,
went through a number of these.
They found that, unlike the
US, which was thinning out its
ecosystem for its manufacturers,
that its small and mid-sized
manufacturers, in particular,
were more "home alone,"
Germany was doing the opposite--
a much more connected,
collaborative system,
right-- in part through a
Fraunhofer network system that,
starting at the end of World War
II and partially, by the way,
paid for by the
Marshall Plan by the US,
brought large and small
and mid-sized firms.
In Germany, the small
and mid-sized firms
are called Mittelstand.
And it's a famous German
capability, these very talented
small and mid-sized firms.
They were able to
bring them together
in collaborations around new
innovations in production.
And they would work together,
assisted by German engineering
academics in the process.
They have 60 of these
Fraunhofer institutes,
really manufacturing institutes,
spread all over the country.
So they have a way of avoiding
the "home alone" problem.
If anything, they're
ever enriching
the collaboration
between their firms
and the trade-off of ideas.
They have a whole system
for collaborative R&D
that's shared between the
small and mid-sized firms
and the larger firms.
Through that system, they
have the most famous workforce
training system in
the world, through
a remarkable
apprenticeship system
that consistently
produces incredibly highly
skilled workers.
And the apprenticeships
will last
for three or four years, right.
Really in-depth training.
We have nothing like that.
We have highly
decentralized labor markets
in the United States.
We have nothing close to this.
So they have a whole
shared training
system for their workforce.
And they've developed
ways through
these collaborative
mechanisms to rapidly scale up
their production.
So Germany's workforce in
manufacturing is 80% unionized.
We're not remotely
close to that.
It's a different system.
It's hard for the US to do an
apprenticeship system here.
It doesn't quite match the
way we organize things.
But there are some ideas
that we could learn from.
And the seventh and last
story is about jobs.
The manufacturing sector
affects our services sector.
And Suzanne Berger and the team
tell an interesting story here,
that the 21st
century firm, right,
is going to increasingly
tie a complex hard product
to a service and link
them, and offer customers
solutions-- not a
good or a service,
but a solution to a problem.
So your Apple
iPhone, in many ways,
is a combined service delivery
hardware technology, right.
There's lots of service delivery
through that Apple iPhone,
right.
Things are going to be more
like that in the future.
Now, personal services
tend to be face-to-face.
And they're hard to
scale up quickly, right.
It's their kind of one-to-one
relationship building.
And that process
takes a long time.
Whereas if you're producing
a manufactured good,
you can produce one
product on day 1.
On day 12, you can produce
a million products, right.
You can scale very quickly--
much faster than through a
personal service operation,
right.
So one advantage
of manufacturing
is that it tends to scale
up the gains in your economy
much more quickly.
Part of the reason
why it took so long
to recover from the
2007, 2008 recession
is that we had so damaged
our manufacturing sector
that the normal scale-up
coming out of a recession just
wasn't happening.
It was taking forever.
But if you're able to combine
a tradable good, right, that
can scale with a
service, then the service
starts to become
tradable as well, right--
and can scale.
So that's a whole new
capability in services
that we haven't really spent
a lot of time thinking about.
But it's very interesting,
since 86% of our workforce
is in services.
Maybe we ought to work
on this territory.
But a prerequisite is
having the tradable goods
that you can tie to
a service, right.
Yet another reason why, in
the next generation of firms,
manufacturing capability
is going to be important.
You saw this chart before.
This shows you where societal
returns come from, right.
Predominantly from
production, not from services.
So let me just summarize.
Here's the stories that Suzanne
and the PIE study taught us.
Manufacturing is
not agriculture.
This sector was hollowing out.
It wasn't enjoying productivity
advances to the extent
we thought possible.
Our manufacturing firms are
increasingly "home alone."
Their ecosystems of
support are thinned out.
There's less of what Pisano
and Shih called a "commons"
available to support them.
There's a real scale-up problem
for small, mid-sized firms,
and for startup firms, for
somewhat different reasons.
There's important linkage
between innovation
and production.
These are very related
and tied to each other.
And if you lose one,
it'll affect the other.
There's interesting
lessons about workforce,
that we've got a problem ahead
in up-scaling our workforce.
It's not an emergency
now, but we probably
have a problem ahead.
Very important
lessons from Germany
on the societal benefits of
a strong production sector.
And then, in this
jobs area, if you're
able to tie tradable
goods to services,
then the services themselves
become tradable and scalable,
as well.
And then, there's an
underlying question
about how our manufacturing
sector, therefore,
affects our services sector.
So let's come back and do
some questions about this.
And then we'll dive into
the next round of readings.
And Steph will lead us in those.